je va vous demander de de vous
lever mesdames et messieurs les
ministres c'est avec tristesse que nous
avons appris le 25 novembre dernier la
disparition de Gérard Colom Gérard Colom
nous a quitté au terme d'un combat
contre la maladie qu'il menait avec un
grand courage ce matin même ces obsèques
se sont déroulés en la cathédrale
Saint-Jean de Lyon en présence du
président de la République et de madame
la Première ministre qui va nous
rejoindre lors de cette cérémonie
d'adieu à laquelle assisté de nombreux
habitants de sa ville et de son
département ainsi que de nombreuses
personnalités politiques l'émotion était
je le sais présente Matthieu Darnaud
notre premier vice-président y
représenta le Sénat figure emblématique
de la capitale des Gaules Gérard Colom
voit voit sa vie entière à un engagement
inlassable au service de ses
compatriotes et de l'intérêt général ses
facultés d'écoute son esprit de
solidarité était unanimement salué et
suscitaé le respect son élection en 2001
à la mairie de Lyon restura le moment
privilégié de sa vie publique il se
consacrera à sa ville durant plus de 17
ans grâce à lui Lyon fut capable de
rivaliser avec les autres métropole
française et européenne sans pour autant
perdre son âme il transformera sa ville
et mettra toute son énergie au service
de ses de ses
habitants énergie qu'il mettra aussi au
service de la communauté urbaine de Lyon
dont il fut le président il fut aussi
parlementaire élu député dans la 2e
circonscription du rô c'était en juin
1981 il avait 34 ans son arrivé au Sénat
en novembre
1999 marquera sa vie politique il sera
réélu en 2004 et en
2014 il siégea au sein du groupe
socialiste alors présidé par Claude
Estier il devint membre de la commission
des affaires culturelles toujours tourné
vers la modernité il est en 2007
l'auteur d'une proposition de loi
relative à la coopération internationale
des collectivités territorial dans le
domaine des technologies de
l'information et des communications en
2009 il intégra la commission des lois
où ses collègues d'alors peuvent
témoigner de sa connaissance des
dossiers touchant aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
il intervint dans notre hémicycle à
propos de la loi de modernisation de
l'action publique territoriale et
d'affirmation des métropole c'était en
juin 2013 à propos des compétences de la
métropole de Lyon et ce fut je le sais
un temps majeur de sa vie de
sénateur après avoir été l'un des
principaux soutiens d'Emmanuel Macron il
est nommé ministre d'État ministre de
l'Intérieur dans le gouvernement
d'Édouard Philippe il porte devant le
Sénat le projet de loi renforçant la
sécurité intérieure et la lutte contre
le terrorisme visant à transposer dans
le droit commun certaines mesures de
l'état d'urgence et défend en 2018 le
projet de loi sur l'asile et
l'immigration il doit affronter
l'attendat islamiste de trèbe il mesure
le danger du communautarisme qui ronge
notre pays lors de son départ du
ministère de l'Intérieur il laisse ce
message je le cite aujourd'hui on vit
côte à côte je crains que demain on vive
face- à faceace c'est à méditer
l'hommage que nous lui rendons
aujourd'hui n'est pas uniquement
solennel c'est aussi un hommage à un
humaniste un hommage à un défenseur
alinçable de sa ville Lyon et de la
métropole à ses anciens collègues
j'exprime notre sympathie à son épouse à
qui j'ai écrit à ses enfants à toute sa
famille et à tous ceux qui ont partagé
ses engagements je souhaite redire la
part que le Sénat prend à leur chakra et
je vous demande d'observer un moment de
recueillement
je vous
remercie
madame la Première ministre j'avais
annoncé votre décalage lié à votre
retour de Lyon merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs ce matin autour de sa famille
et de ses proches autour du président de
la République autour des habitants de sa
ville nous avons dit adieu un grand
républicain un liyonnais passionné et un
homme
d'État Gérard était un modèle de
réussite
républicaine rien ne le prédestinait ni
à diriger sa ville ni à dééminante
fonction
ministérielle pourtant sa passion pour
les lettres sa force de travail et la
puissance de ses conviction lui ont
permis de devenir enseignant député
sénateur ministre d'État ministre de
l'Intérieur et bien sûr
maire Gérard Colomb a été l'homme d'une
ville pour Lyon il avait un amour réel
sincère inébranlable arpenté sa ville
s'est croisé à chaque coin de rue ses
projets ses idées ses intuitions il
s'est donné corps et âme à sa ville et
la transformer les Lionnais ne
l'oublieront jamais Gérard colon c'était
encore un homme de conviction porté par
la volonté de servir au-delà des
clivages porter par l'attention au
problèmes des Français plutôt qu'aux
étiquettes politiques le Sénat chambre
des territoires et de l'apaisement lui
correspondait bien et chacun dans la
majorité présidentielle sait ce qu'il
lui
doit ad augusta père angusta vers les
voies célestes par des chemins étroits
c'était une de ses devises aujourd'hui
Gérard Colomb a rejoint ses voies
célestes mais son empreinte restera il a
changé la lonnais il a changé la vie des
Français je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre